your book points out some of the most
intense uh things that go on in
scientology but a lot of religions have
this weird cultish kind of crap going on
but people kind of keep quiet about it
the difference is here is you're you're
required to pay a lot of money it costs
a lot of money to be there and also
what's required of
a scientologist which you know i credit
them it's not um an easy thing to be a
scientologist you're required to be
there two and a half hours a day it's a
huge commitment it is financially
emotionally it takes a lot were put into
the scientology program at a very young
age your mom was basically left by your
dad she was desperate she needed to find
a family she needed to find support and
she found it with scientology
and then you're doing all the crap work
the sea org work as they say you know
you're cleaning toilets you're doing
whatever work they want you for low
wages and you're doing all that and
you're paying for courses on top of that
blah blah blah blah your career goes
along
even before king of queens you know
you're getting some work on tv and
suddenly you're blessed by going to the
celebrity
center right and wow in a way that sort
of is an eye-opener too what do you mean
now because i have a high profile job
i'm suddenly treated like a queen i mean
you know that probably really was the
crack in the cosmic egg for you well you
know the the way it's set up celebrity
center is set up for the artist
it's so seductive correct i mean because
here you are you know you you know i'm
coming from ben's and hers you know
you're going in the sea work was a
different story because we were living
in a mote i mean i was like things are
better in brooklyn than this but then as
a parishioner you know when we went to
l.a we were you know sleeping on
somebody's floor and we had no money and
we were paying for scientology and
trying to get on our feet
and yes you know here you are you go to
this beautiful building you know when
they
bring you lunch it's on a tray they have
beautiful restaurants suddenly tom
cruise talks to you which came later
that comes with king queen because then
i realized like i was like oh i'm not
even in the right part of the celebrity
center there's another part oh my god
you know what i love about you seriously
and i'm going to commend you for this
good most of us as human beings would be
very very seduced by the celebrity
center we'd kind of say you know what
i've arrived you get seduced by hanging
out with all these celebrities and you
kind of say you know what life's kind of
easy and fun i'm accepted into the group
i'm hanging out with the leader of
scientology i'm like i'm the [ __ ]
and you could have just kind of stayed
kept your mouth shut and yet you kind of
said wait a second i'm at the highest
level right and now i see the true
hypocrisy and i don't think many people
would have given up that uh acceptance
and that style of life i really truly
thank you
and i have my family honestly how i
don't know if i could do it my mom
you know was there for me my stepfather
they all left with me that that is a big
thing i mean a lot of people's lives are
destroyed a lot of people don't leave
with their family